[Musique]
place de la République un événement hors
du commun se prépare dans la capitale
cette soirée consiste à montrer aux
Réunionnais que les loin de chez eux
parce que
le département est toujours à la poseur
le département est toujours à côté de
Réunionnais c'est vrai que ça fait
partie des projets du département pour
montrer que la culture aide à
l'épanouissement des gens accompagner
les Réunionnais installés en métropole
dans le cadre de la mobilité c'est le
sens
des missions de notre service le service
d'accompagnement et de proximité de
Paris et c'est aussi
rassembler les réunionnais et aussi
faire découvrir la culture réunionnaise
au plus grand nombre d'habitude
que ça nous fait bon moi je me maquille
et lui je sais pas ce qu'il cherche
mes lunettes
donc voilà quoi c'est génial tous les
cas
j'espère que ça sera une belle soirée et
qu'on va on va faire une bonne ambiance
tout ensemble avec les Réunionnais même
les gens qui ne sont pas réunionnais
mais qui aiment la musique et voilà quoi
ça c'est génial
que chaleur cette chaleur la Réunion on
apé 11000 km avec les artistes que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure la balance peu
importe cette émotion quand il y a que
n'oublie pas
parce que il veut dire oh que si
n'oublie pas Lila c'est que nous attrape
les artistes de 90 2000 podia ces jeunes
voilà où ça va commencer voilà où ça va
commencer notre histoire d'aujourd'hui
21 juin elle nous donne paquet ces
artistes allez là ben justement
redonnons à l'histoire de la Réunion
s'il y a pas intérêt
une édition placée sous le thème du
souvenir
enir raggas Sega maloya les artistes
majeurs de la scène réunionnaise des
années 97 2000 se sont déplacés de quoi
réjouir les amateurs
[Musique]
tout ça bonne événements autant
longtemps il manque un petit peu et là
c'est le moment pour vider un peu au
revoir c'est important ça permet aux
personnes expatriés d'avoir consommé
d'accrocher avec lui
danser et on est bien content que le
département il fait la fête de la
musique pour nous parce qu'il faut pas
oublier aussi
la Réunion
elle vient de loin et bien de notre
propre
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les temps sont durs et donc
la musique peut vraiment faire un
genre de médicaments pour le cerveau
pour le corps pour l'âme tout le temps
donc bonne fête de la musique à toute
comme nous c'est un groupe pour nous
dire c'est un peu la nostalgie donc les
gens ils retrouvent un petit peu nos
musiques et il fait les autres comme un
jeune flashback et un jour nous apporter
cette chaleur il pense que l'important
d'être loin et de voir la Réunion venir
parce que mamie ça va des concerts
aussi on fait l'émotion en plus parce
que à la réunion nous les dents tous les
jours je coupe peut-être que nous
comprend pas et si pareil il fait un
petit frisson un petit truc à fierté du
coup voilà ça a été pour moi en plus de
Vigner un jeu pour balleronner les
valable mais surtout moi monsieur maloya
mais ramène maloya musique la Réunion il
appartient à la Réunion il ramène ça
côté Paris mais plusieurs franchement le
contentement féminin
à travers des événements comme ça et
aussi lui a découvert la culture à
réunionnaise au public qui ne nous
connaît pas
un plaisir de le regarder là la réunion
rassemble et ce soir voir tout le temps
de mon présent sur la place de la
République à Paris c'est un événement
extraordinaire les Réunionnais école et
à Paris c'est là que tu rentres que
doit-il importantes et là il croit que
nous la main ce soir parce que là le
cœur banal et ça mais parce que les
inégalable nous la marque le département
la marque un point fort ce soir
et pour finir cette belle soirée sur
tirage au sort en Réunionnais a eu la
chance de se voir offrir par le
Département un aller-retour pour son île
[Applaudissements]
d'avion on perd pas le département de La
Réunion faut aller voir en famille
profiter du soleil
pour fédérer encore plus de Réunionnais
l'événement a poursuivi sa route jusqu'à
Lyon avec une promesse celle de
s'étendre à d'autres villes pour l'année
prochaine
[Musique]